it starts like this
satellite okay okay that's the best
thing you've ever said by the way
yeah because your tone down as they come
it's called improving it's called being
a good singer and continuing to sing and
getting even better it's called you know
all right
all right next one this is a good
episode
drunk
[Music]
gonna blow up
there we go there we go here we go there
we go here we go remember in the first
few minutes don't swear because that's
when we get demonetized okay have you
ever noticed the Sprouts like the
vegetable look like sperm
uh no actually you never thought that
why do people not think about this and
talk about it more I don't sprouts look
like sperms I mean
I exactly like sperms
I'm trying to keep it clean so it'll
curse for the first 10 minutes
I don't know if it does a little bit it
does yeah but if they look more of a bud
on the end of a
oh I see no I see I think it's of a
curved head yeah I think it's like a uh
a fat part that goes into into an egg
and then and then the squiggly part okay
is like
the body of the sperm you know yeah I
don't know when I'm eating a sandwich
let's say with Sprouts on it I'm like
wow I'm eating so many sperms okay so
I'm like I've never done this before wow
I guess it does look like it a little
bit yeah yeah look at that it's like but
also it's sometimes they're sprouted
already and it doesn't look like that
okay sure but you know what I'm doing
okay I do you know um
also whenever you put Tabasco
on yeah oh here we go dude you've been
saying this for decades it's the only
thing that comes out I don't know if it
has to do with the top or what it's the
only thing that comes out like a mess
you know what I'm talking about I don't
want to get the monetized but so but you
can do them you go like this you go like
that and it comes out literally the same
oh oh that's what I'm saying I didn't
even know that's what you're saying okay
yeah yeah that's how much I don't listen
to you you've said that to me so many a
dozen times you never gave me the props
it deserved I mean it's not
it doesn't sound that much like it
deserves props it comes out like that
right that's what we're talking about
yes okay wow it comes out like so coded
okay like about that which we are
talking about right now like you think
that it like you you you don't get it
and then I do it with the Tabasco and
then you get it and you're like okay no
that is the witch what he is talking
about right but that is that okay at
which which he is talking about fine oh
by the way dude welcome back oh oh to me
yeah thanks yeah you were sick better
for a day did a solo episode because I
was having the baby and then you got
sick again yeah so what happened is I
had covid which everybody knows because
everybody in the world listens to the
show and they heard me when I solo
hosted I had covered okay the day I
hosted was the middle day of about
five days that I felt good for the only
week in April that I felt good wow then
after five days or so of getting all
better from covid I got
strep throat those are two great things
to have back to back now here's the
thing strep throat is a gazillion times
worse than coven right unless you're
like old and fat and have some other
comorbidity will kill you but for most
people covet is just like
yeah a bad call a bad cold right yes so
the uh the strepto was like I was dying
you know that one time I was the last
time I stripped out I called you yep in
the middle of the night I remember I was
going Delirious I had 103 fever and I
was so so so sick what what was I what
why did I call because I thought I was
gonna die you didn't understand what was
happening and then by the time the phone
call was over I was like Matt I think
you just have a fever and you were like
oh I haven't had a fever before and you
actually were talking about how you
never really had a fever oh I was like
this is what a fever feels like he's
like you're like why do I feel like
things are happening they're not
happening and I'm like oh yeah is what a
fever does he's like oh okay I never
really get fevers but I get sick a lot
which is bad
it's good to get fevers when you're sick
but wait I knew it more than you okay so
you don't know you don't have you don't
get fevers that's so it's rare that I
get a fever I got a fever with strepto
because it was absolutely brutal
experience but strep is something that
gives anyone who gets it fevers because
it's such a gnarly it's a staff gnarly
dude it's like in the family of staph
infections like that yeah they have
which other people killer ones that
spread around hospitals and kill
everybody you cut off my joke wow I'm
pissed okay ship what was it I said you
said it's a staph infection I said yeah
because I have a whole bunch of people
working for it wow it's yeah okay yeah I
didn't hear it you don't know you didn't
even have a chance I don't know how much
I loved it but I should get you know
what it is you're not giving me all my
props for what I do okay twice not
that's twice now that you're not giving
me my props I'm saying things and you're
just disregarding it when it's like when
I speak there's weight to it okay okay
yeah crushed under that weight you also
swear I said ship
you said [__] and we got to bleep it out
but it's okay but anyway we're five
minutes into the episode but what so
it's nice to have you back thank you we
shook things up a little bit and that's
okay and now we're back now what we ask
is that you like and subscribe yeah
that's it it's not it's not even a lot
to ask no it's not a lot to ask just
like a subscriber dude you're watching
this for free right they're watching it
for free so why don't you just like And
subscribe it helps us out leave a
comment for the algorithm and then also
I'll be in Columbus in Cincinnati so you
can go to Salt Lake City you can go to
Tucson bring up my dates you can go to
you can get tickets from Montreal you
can get tickets for uh Nashville uh
Detroit chrisley.com
um and uh Boise Pueblo Colorado for some
reason Knoxville Tennessee for some
reason Arkansas for some reason
Ottawa Edmonton Hamilton Cleveland not a
place Orlando and Fort Myers Florida for
some reason so chrisley.com don't push
me tour there we go Pueblo Colorado is
okay so that's they show the picture
that's the only nice picture they have
have you ever basically Gangland noticed
when something terrible happens in the
in the country it's always in obviously
Florida
or Texas
or the Dark Horse surprising Place
Colorado yeah right Littleton Pueblo uh
there's always terrible stuff happening
and uh what's the crazy like woke place
don't you mean Denver no no no the the
the one wherever but no bad things
happen in Aurora though yeah we know
that yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
um don't make that noise so there's uh
whatever you do again don't ever do that
Little Rock Memphis is also number like
crazy crazy bad is it did if you ever
watch First 48 it's like and of course
in Memphis we're in Memphis of course
but okay but do this anytime you guys
read YouTube Not Just solicitors
look at where it happened like on the
byline where the authors The Writer's
name is it'll say reporting from you
know whatever Atlanta Georgia
I'm telling you
almost all the time it'll be Florida
Texas and then Dark Horse Colorado what
about the guy who did the stuff who
killed this whole family and that was in
Florida too right I mean people do that
a lot Chris
yeah yeah uh Chris Watts the bad one
yeah dude Chris Watts
lie better Chris what's up what's up
dude Chris
what's up with how bad you are online
dude he was like when they said that
when you see the body cam that's the
best [__] it's so funny yeah
it's like
it was like that like he's just like I
don't know you know I know his cell
phone's over there but no I don't know
you know yeah do you know where she the
officers are just asking about the
normal stuff enough
yeah no I don't know you know who's that
my wife I don't yeah okay he's like you
know he's like that Meme the Conor
McGregor meme where it's like you when
you ask when when your girl when your
friend's girlfriend asked if he was with
you last night and he's like you know
what I'm talking about I don't think I
know that Chris dude pull it up it's so
funny I don't even know the guy you know
it's like dude it's so funny he's like
it wasn't wasn't me I thought it wasn't
that oh what the [__] dude it's so funny
here watch it wow a whole bunch of UFC
stuff's gonna come up obviously because
he wrote defensive Conor McGregor see
that wasn't good that wasn't good
because
there's no way that I'm gonna be able to
find this in the amount of time that you
think cheating Conor McGregor
meme cheating Conor McGregor wow Chris
dude how could you get that so bad
defensive don't be like look at look at
a picture of Ken Griffey Jr dancing and
then right here there it is right there
go ahead right exactly what I did what
happened absolutely nothing I don't know
I just I just showed up and I don't know
just I don't even know the guy to be
honest with you
just rumors nothing happened with me
play it again dude
absolutely nothing I don't know I just I
just showed up and I don't know just I
don't even know the guy to be honest
with you
just really almost nothing happened with
me
it's such a great it's such a great I
mean because he's so seems dude he is so
funny like he's kind of got that Trump
thing where he's funny like even if he's
not trying to be yeah yeah like what a
crazy Persona he has yeah I know you are
a man you are a man that's one of my
favorite the walk he does yeah it sure
is hilarious you are a man you are a man
oh yeah dude yeah we start laughing like
it might do play that one that one's so
funny I don't know you know I don't know
uh Conor McGregor defensive fighting
punch out kick UFC
yeah
fresh
you the man you the man
you are the man
dude wow I don't he's so beefy right now
it's so weird he's like but his face is
bigger he's obviously taking something
but like he's on the originals well not
that but yeah something I mean it's just
Kansas City Royal knows nope okay that's
not good I thought it might be
um so okay tour chrisley.com get your
tickets leave a message on the hotline
213-973-8095 that's
213-973-8095 for the hotline and
Lifeline wow throw up the robot threw up
okay uh what you want one-on-one advice
book it pay me I'll listen to you and
guess what I'll give you the best the
best advice you ever had devices but yes
the best you ever had you never seen
anything like it you never even heard of
any advice like the kind that I give it
is priceless and yet I'm selling it for
a price wow now it's up to you if you
guys want it you guys take it if you
don't okay you're [__] stupid but no
okay and then also the new Lifeline
merch which is absolutely yes it is uh
lifelinemerch.com and there's also new
crystalia merch grow or die that stuff
chrisley.com and that's so anyway
um says you say it so fast
you are the fast talker have you ever
seen an interview with the Micro
Machines guy no it's crazy how much of a
he says like
some he can he can say all of the words
of some book yeah I have like 20 minutes
and it's like Moby Dick or something
insane yep what about I know that we oh
watch out for the Perrier there's a
secret about these shoes you want to
know it yeah people mistake them for a
birthday cake rude looks like you eat
them with a fork of the plastic fork
these are so awesome look at the Nike
vomero fives
there's a little secret about these
shoes that you don't know about okay
you're right what is it yep uh so I saw
them on Instagram and I wanted them I
look at them and I go got to have it and
then I saw it and I go
I'm gonna order it and I go on the line
for Nike to my chagrin 160 bucks I'm
like not bad right not bad if you know
your boy I'll drop a rack on shoes yeah
unfortunately and so um I go to get the
shoes and I look and it says women's
whoa so I go what that's kind of cool
though and I'm like but yeah it's cool
but then it's like now I I can't get my
size but then I'm like oh of course yeah
there's someone with some big what size
is Brittany Greiner I don't know so I'm
like yeah yeah that's a good question
what is 13 in women's 14.5 looked it up
this is a 14.5 in women's and what if
it's perfect if it's great why did you
but you looked up what's 14.5 no I'm
sorry I looked up what's 13 in women's
what's that men's 13 in women's okay
you're right and it said really it's
only a one one another
a half above all the way through all
sizes I I believe I think it might be
shorter on the edges
probably what I said but yeah okay maybe
not so I got these shoes and I'm a woman
now
so I wow I'm a trans activist is that
how that happens
and I think that Dylan Mulvaney is a
beautiful woman and that's cool and I
think that she's level-headed wow
hitting all the Talking Points huh okay
well that's crazy that ending is really
crazy but what was the reason you
brought up the shoes because they're new
and I'm wearing them for the first time
and but not because they're women's
well no I the secret that was the cool
like part right that was a secret you
wouldn't give away it you wouldn't give
it away in the trailer for the for the
movie right that was the secret that
would be the part of the movie where
you're like oh and they're women's okay
all right well this wasn't in the
trailer but I'm glad I it's the plot
twist did you see the hater the movie
the hater no man and you know how you
should know that because I told you that
last night I only watched polar films I
suppose that's not true it's on Netflix
even not that's not even remotely true
that you only watch polish films but why
because I watched because I see a lot of
because I watch a lot of Gerard Butler
movies yeah I saw I saw hunter killer
too and that's something juicy plain
speaking of draw Butler no but you did
I don't want to see that one's gonna
believe me it's good it has good stuff
in it whoa really are the whole plane
crash sequence is like an hour it's only
like half of the movie is on I know but
that's what it looked like that but it's
see I thought it was just like get him
crashed and then let's get to the guns
but then it wouldn't be called plane
right exactly it should be called plane
Aina AI oh it shouldn't be playing a-i-n
p-l-a-i-n it shouldn't be called
um it shouldn't be called plane no
matter what
yeah it should it should be called like
lost in the jungle or whatever it should
have a title not just a random noun as
the title yeah it would be like if the
Godfather was called shooting
pasta and shooting or or Mafia guys yeah
Mafia guys Mafia guys wow wouldn't be
considered the best move of all time no
not even close yeah
um so anyway dude uh I want I won't I
don't really want to watch a plane I I
wanna I almost watched Scream Six last
night don't watch that I saw screen five
or whatever it was so bad dude the lead
in that it's a bummer how bad it is the
woman is so hot whoever that is
see I don't even know the new cast at
all I only know the last one of the
original series however the whole new
series right uh it's like all kids yeah
yeah yeah yeah
like Courtney Cox isn't in it she is
yeah she is she's in it yeah they're all
like people continue they're all like
whatever the world in the original they
were
in the original were they in college
they were in high school the original
was the reporter I know that because in
this one there are adults
no the college was screamed too yeah
it's high school but the kids now it's a
little older it's not they're not in
high school well they were kids in the
fifth one they were yeah oh and they
were I think they were in college even
then yeah we're not figuring out a cool
thing okay the thing we're figuring
isn't even cool okay yeah so okay cool
no matter what the truth is about all
the things they're asking me it doesn't
matter because knowing that is not
important informative interesting or
cool okay okay cool sounds great
so uh anyways uh Scream Six I didn't see
it so that oh wow even more not
interesting so that was even possible
[Laughter]
ha ha
you met and Chris this is too quiet it's
too quiet
I'm sorry I'll turn it up that's my
fault my bad all right cool
hey Matt and Chris he's just quiet
Carnegie Hall [__] bleed New York
there's all that [__] whatever anyways
um my boyfriend
got an issue he likes to go on hiking
trips and he's got this like hiking crew
um and I'm always telling him like Hey I
want to go like that sounds awesome I
want to go and we've done that kind of
stuff before like he knows I'm into it I
can do it
um but every time it comes up he kind of
gives me this excuse as to why I can't
go and it's either it's not his house
that they're staying at or he's not
driving or it's all boys or blah blah
blah whatever and like I guess some of
the excuses are valid but I guess my
question is like how can I avoid feeling
hurt and left out every time
he goes hiking without me because I want
to go hiking I want to see the mountains
bro anyways
help thank you sometimes they're really
bad for him yeah me too it's interesting
because you gotta you know guy time and
girl time whatever whatever you are uh
is important you know and sometimes you
want to do the stuff in guy time that
the girl wants to do
but you're like sweetie this is Guy time
but we can go on a hike but does she
want to go with the uh with her his crew
I don't know what I would have asked her
is what if he went on as many hikes with
you as he did with his boys or whatever
I mean would that solve Dr Quinn right
but I'm saying would that solve the
problem no questions the answer to the
question gets to my point okay so if she
says then that that wouldn't
that wouldn't be the same thing then I
think she might have a problem if it
would be the same thing and she's just
hurt that he ignores her oh yeah then
that would you know what I'm saying good
point he would be the one with the
problem good point I just I I think that
that's a good question to ask yourself
but uh I think if your question is how
do I not get my feelings heard
I mean that's a I don't I don't know
things that hurt my feelings I wish I
knew how to know maybe your codependent
feelings yeah maybe uh codependent a
little bit but it's fine but also work
on it and I know about that and I
[__] think about it
okay okay cool are you so what are you
codependent yeah no not at all yeah
um I want to be alone all the time the
entire time of always so how come I'm
codependent then uh because I don't know
we have the same family
of course we have different experiences
obviously
drastically different experience I don't
like that I'm codependent or not that's
not fair oh I see what you're saying
well I'm the [__] man and that was
true even when I was born you are the
man the man the man could be codependent
codependent and I'm codependent and if
somebody doesn't feel good about
something that has to do with me then I
am not okay great okay it's great right
okay so no it's great if Kristen is like
do the dishes and I don't do them and
then the next morning I wake up it's
just upset about the dishes not being
done I feel like the dishes dirty and
like trash yeah great and that's great
well I don't know if it's great but it's
okay that you photo that and I need her
to feel good for me to feel good this
isn't your therapy okay I understand the
show is not your therapy for the hiking
thing yeah the hiking thing I think that
first of all ask yourself that question
second uh I think that to actually try
to avoid getting your feelings heard I
think you should make an effort because
that sucks it sucks to have your
feelings are repeatedly and if you know
there's a possible defense against it
you should take it I think the the
defense against it
the real one the natural one the true
one is that it isn't about you as much
as that might suck to also know it's a
separate and it's a different thing and
you say you say this to Kristen
I I I
get my acceptance to other people and
that's a problem but go ahead
shut up because you're only talking
about you okay right all right cool so
uh
wow yes you are right though yeah dude
is it if you're taking it personally you
control how personally you take
something uh so if you're asking how to
lessen that feeling tell yourself that
it isn't about you it's not meaning it's
not personal he has his own mind his own
interior life and sometimes you got to
give it up to that also dude yo give it
up for the interior live but also dude
you don't
um know
uh you can also how
you can busy yourself with other things
too like once you get in your feelings
go out and do something your own and you
know if you're just sitting stewing at
it that makes it worse and I don't know
if you are or not it looks like you're
you like the outdoors you gotta I mean
you got a [__] uh orange vest on so
you're doing something pretty Scenic
yeah Place shoes she did that obviously
to further her point about how we she
wanted us on her side but we we do we
understand and uh yeah
for sure
how so because you're saying that she
the woman like over planned to make us
think a certain thing to trick us you
know
good dude
it's all good um
stop doing it it's Dave Matthews style
satellite oh my God satellites
dude it's not oh my God satellites oh my
God subtle it's all it's bad anyway
satellite no one knows the other words
no one knows the other words well also
even the guy with the violins like
how to sing the word satellite in a song
he says it so many times in that song
because it's called satellite
all right okay so what is it satellite
oh dude pulled up satellite defensive
UFC punch that's what he Googled
Satellite lyrics satellite Dave Matthews
dude
satellite in my eyes like a diamond in
the sky how I wonder satellite's
stronger from the moon or whatever
that's not the tune it's it sucks it
starts like this
satellite okay okay that's the best
thing you've ever said by the way no
[__] yeah because you're [__]
tone definitely it's called improving
it's called being a good singer and
continuing to sing and getting even
better and that's what your notice
called you know
should we should we blow dry your hair
and he goes like this finish him dude
unbelievable
[Laughter]
foreign
like you typed in as a prompt like cool
International guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the image right yeah I would spit
that out yeah all right cool if he has a
low voice if he has a low voice forget
it Mexican low boys
that's gonna be a soft pretty okay sweet
voice
what's up need some advices boys uh
Chris long long long time listener and
Matt we love you to death that is cool
okay guys so I've been shot incredible
exchange and Crossroads for a long long
time it's a fun spot to buy sell trade
Etc whatever so here's the gist I
brought in a Yeezy shirt like a gap easy
shirt and a pair of fear of God pants
and I was denied both items what because
the Apparently both are associated with
Kanye's had his moment in the media of
stirring up quite a frenzy
but I'm sure myself and other people
still like to wear his stuff he's
listening to his music whatever there's
plenty of other people who have their
hands in these projects right yes
um also the fear of God pants have
nothing no you're nothing Kanye but
after seeing the shirt the girl the
counter claims that Kanye also owns fear
of God which she does not so anyways am
I the jerk for bringing these in and
thinking that other people may be
interested in these products
um or is maybe the world crumbling away
and people are starting to die on this
really silly Hill that seems to
accomplish nothing so anyways so leading
the witness is a 30 year old man just
sitting here bummed out because I was
treated like this so beautiful that's a
second hand used clothing store what is
going on that guy's [__] god
dude he's got it together so for this to
bother him means that he's just like God
at all yeah but he's also maybe a serial
killer for this to bother him there's no
way that guys well no there's not yeah
but that would that would throw me for a
loop though you know what I'm saying
yeah I I have a rule and you just you
buy what you like I don't it's too hard
to if you're gonna look obviously Kanye
is a mess him being against Semitic is
just stupid
if if look then look into everybody's
company like so this person supports
that person so you can't go to [__]
Chick-fil-A because they support
whatever they support and then it's just
like dude it's too much work as a
consumer I'm gonna buy what I like the
way it looks to put on myself and if I
like the way something tastes I'm gonna
eat it I'll period also how good is your
life if this is a hill you want to die
just there's you have the best life ever
if this is the hill you've chosen to die
on it makes people feel good because it
makes people feel like they matter and
they're doing the right thing even
though it's just [__] man it it just
I don't I I think by the way those are
cool outfits keep those the Kanye West
Gap shirt is cool and the fear of God
short pants you don't understand that
guy doesn't need them I know you can
walk around with no shirt on and I know
that he's men and women will follow him
home I understand and he can [__] men or
women in the ass whenever he wants
anytime but I don't know
I don't I don't
go to the next Buffalo Exchange they'll
be like okay yeah that might be true I
think what he's saying is there's a
store policy-wide thing store-wide
policy yeah well that'll change in
[__] two weeks anyway you know what I
mean it's like yeah I mean that's the
that is the thing to remember for to the
beautiful guy so he can keep in mind
this is going coming and going just like
everything else has in the past yeah
that everyone was freaking out about and
then stopped caring about because they
got tired because you can't tense a
muscle forever you gotta loosen up
sometimes you can't keep a muscle tense
always non-stop it's just too much to be
it's too much to be outraged all the
time and to be that way is to be
outraged all the time and it's
exhausting to do that that's my point is
too much work
it's so much work but what I said in the
way that I delivered it was spectacular
the way I did it you did the thing where
you kind of like cut it off at the knees
and then you were like here's the simple
way to say it yeah because that way it
reaches more of the people who are
listening but what I did was like an
Edward Murrow thing and you ruined it is
my is my I didn't ruin it you kind of
you you tackled it you tackled It To The
Ground I don't think I did you did I
didn't everyone rewind about a minute
and listened to my amazing sermon
and then look how Chris cut it off at
the knees okay and ruined everything
about it all right well I think that
it's gonna be fine keep the clothes for
a little bit you'll be able to sell them
soon or try to sell them online dude
[__] that person it's it's if it's a car
if it's a policy
for the company then go to another
there's others Consignments also just
wait dude yeah yeah also yeah there are
other consignment shops and they that
thing whatever you're selling or
reselling has has a price in the market
regardless of what that particular
person or store policy dictates yeah and
that price is high because those things
are valuable yeah there we go okay okay
next
hi is the Lemon person
um I'm really bummed that I couldn't
find the lemon filter again but that's
this is I guess
um Coming Out of the Shadows but update
that friend and I from the solo mad
episode we just fizzled out dude
um naturally organically which is fine
but I have a new question
because now my husband is like skeptical
every time I make a new friend and he's
like is this person gonna hate me blah
blah blah and I'm like no probably not
but also
I don't I don't know
but my other friend was there when it
was like Rocky so maybe like her vision
was tainted and I don't know is Mario in
the background like now I'm scared to
like have new friends gotta Wonder
Chris she was on Twitch or something
explain so
um
she called in with a question about her
friend she she was friends with somebody
who didn't like her husband and was
always saying things like when are you
gonna divorce your house oh [__] cut
that front out relax but keep going and
so we Matt gave her advice and she's
like oh I cut that person out of my life
good I was right
and then retrospect and now she says her
husband kind of has PTSD about her
getting new friends and was wondering if
they're also gonna hate him and stuff so
but that's her that's her new question
yeah okay so pts your husband is gonna
be fine yeah because he
has balls of spine and a brain you know
what I mean balls of spine and her brain
so if those things would tell me that
he's gonna be fine because the pts he
suffered wasn't actually PTSD and
frankly it's uh abominable to equate the
two things
um but but to stick with your term your
husband's PTSD is is gonna not be there
for a very long time yeah let's start
there that's a horseshit yeah that that
is it's it's swung so far the other way
that now I'm like maybe your friend was
right to hate this guy right there we go
we're getting more you know what I'm
talking about it yeah oh dude hey oh hey
hubby congratulations you just fed me a
bunch of horseshit yeah yeah yeah that's
[__]
PTSD when you make whenever you make a
friend it triggers my PTSD
sometimes deep deep dark wrong with them
deep dark wrong
in the 90s dude deep dark wrong with
with with Wesley Snipes and a wrestler
and a WWE such a movie outer watch and
also uh Rucker Howard would be the best
yeah dude and also uh um who's the guy
oh [__] whim hurt oh wow this is an
amazing cast Rucker Hower William Hurt
and Wesley Snipes in deep dark wrong wow
dude you throwing William Hurt in there
it's changing the complexion of the
movie so much it's actually well done
yeah it sounds kind of good right now
um yeah anyway okay okay so that one
well you know he'll get over it let's
let's be to put a nice shine on it he'll
get over yep okay cool and Madeline's
though
wow just still making the movie uh my
question pertains to my professional
life a little bit and a little bit of my
personal life
conditioning coach for almost 10 years
now and whenever I talk about work or
talk about Fitness in general somebody
always has to say something absurd that
they did athletically in high school my
favorite one recently someone told me
that they back squatted 700 pounds when
they were 16 in high school okay and
obviously they didn't yeah I think that
would be a pretty big record that I
would hear about and I just want to say
something back that's not too smartassie
um but it just kind of undermines my
profession a little bit when people talk
about things that yeah I get that they
obviously didn't do and then they say
something along the lines of oh I'm too
broken to do that now like wait until
you're my age and your knees are all
jacked up and like it just kind of yeah
on my skin so yeah um any sort of spin
movementality tips on that which is
greatly appreciated
the same thing is when people say to me
like oh people I'm funny people people's
people yeah my friends say I should be a
comedian okay great and I agree but
you're making it about you again but
that's so I'm codependent okay so now to
make it back about him we can get back
to you whenever you want okay but just
to make it about it
probably do that now to make it
medicated about him uh real quick what
you should say is I when the guy says I
bench here you be the guy that is saying
he I back squat 700 pounds when I was
16. really what uh what record book is
that in that I can read about because
that's that that's a that's an I know my
stuff that is a world record that would
be amazing that would be the most
amazing thing ever so do that okay
I just didn't tell anybody
then do what I'm doing you do what I'm
doing yeah except you right now yeah
photographic evidence but you know there
weren't cell phones back then dude I uh
that is that is a ludicrous claim and to
take someone like who's being that
ridiculous there's nothing that you can
do back that is more ridiculous it's
like saying I flew
I flew I I flew conditional therapy I've
flown in the sky you do physical
conditioning I flew when I was 20 I flew
so yeah you don't I bet you can't do
that you know yeah yeah people a lot
people honestly lie all the [__] time
anyway so oh dude 85 what everyone says
is a lie is that a stat no it's what I'm
it's my it's Matt's book of stats worst
book Matt the stat book well I remember
what mom used to call you Matt this time
yep wanna know why I do know why why
well you say you'll say it better so
does it no I don't know and I'll tell
you right now I know you know I know uh
I would memorize all the statistics of
my favorite baseball players by reading
the back of them so people knew say that
says the same time it's you because I
knew you knew I knew but I wanted people
to know I knew
noobs okay man imagine if you did that
if you're a therapist
I actually want to I want to hear from
Chris about I had therapy the other day
about what when uh childhood oh sorry
that when people say that they think
they're funny yeah too and that they
should be on stage like
what do you say to those people uh yeah
I mean we were riffing and whatever but
you know it's all good I usually say oh
yeah
um
actually what's come to mind is one time
a person
I was at a bar
this is a really long time ago this is
before I I like
people knew kind of knew who I was
almost came out the wrong way and they
do now before I was just
alarmingly famous and
um alarmingly uh this woman came out to
me and she was like see your comedian I
was like yeah and she was like so are
you funny I was like I don't know man
you know it's to some people I guess and
she was like
um why don't you say tell me a joke
which is uh it happens all the time and
I said I uh nah you know if I don't
wanna I don't wanna she's like come on
just a joke I was like nah this is just
stupid where to par you know and like
you won't laugh because you're ready for
it and nah and she was like just do any
joke it's fine any joke of yours and I
was like I don't want to do that soon
about four times it wasn't comfortable
with me because this woman was just a
[__] and I was just laying into her
stand right at her you know what I mean
okay okay and she was like one said it
again and I said you know what
I'm not gonna do a joke but if you
really want you can just go online I
have jokes on there type in my name and
watch my stuff and she goes like this
ew in no way I can't believe you just
said that yeah I believe that yeah and I
was like man
you made me this way but did she
obviously didn't want to see you stand
up interested in talking to you and
having a moment that you could tell her
friends about yeah or just
there's a number of us you wanted
probably the Dill's neck
she probably wanted to build okay well I
can't and then that's the dumbest thing
you've ever seen and then I hit and then
I hit it a little strong didn't I I said
why don't you why don't you just [__]
Google me back when you could Google me
bro you knew you knew that that when you
were saying that to her you must have
known that that's she wasn't gonna say
oh oh interesting I know but I wanted to
have that okay so then you okay yeah
because I wanted her to be confronted
with oh he maybe understands that I want
the Dills Nick I said to her just
bringing it back I said to her if she
said to me three times no just do a joke
and I said listen sweetheart
I know what this is all about you want
the Dills neck what do you think she
would have said she would have said what
the dilzneck what is that word
take out ilsna
[Laughter]
you want my dick yeah all right
um yeah so that's what's up
uh you know that's what happens first
that's what's up but then there are
people that say uh what was the thing I
said they say oh I should be a comedian
I now at this point I say oh you
shouldn't now so rude I do I I we had
someone in our family do that recently
yes not recently but yes recently
recently enough but there it's it's it
is 95 to 98 women that do that by the
way and you know why oh really dude to
be perfectly honest
just even being having a brother who's a
comedian but they'll bring no people
will bring it up and they'll do a
similar thing they'll just buy proxy
through me be like oh you know I've
always thought I could do stand-up
comedy with a version of that no but I
was gonna say that they were men but
don't make me have to be a liar but well
that's just your experience I'm not
questioning it I it's like older men oh
wow like dad's age
dude it's like holiday parties what do
you mean yeah family events it is May
better hang out with older men um
holiday parties the war is May you know
the Los Angeles Athletic Club obviously
all right steam rooms so okay
next one
hey Matt hey Chris uh big fan of the
podcast big fan of all of the content
that y'all are putting out
um thank you I am Alyssa I'm located in
Indianapolis so if we could get some
indie tour dates that'd be lovely
um I'm gonna predicament so I'm a fourth
year teacher and I'm pretty heavily
tattooed already right
um I'm about to finish this sleeve and I
have like my leg done as well so I am
thinking about getting life rips
tattooed on my fingers here and I don't
know if that's a great idea I do already
have my cuticles done but they're not
super noticeable and so I don't know if
that would kind of mess up my career
options in the future my district seems
okay with it but I don't know if I want
to be here forever so any and all advice
would be lovely I love y'all I miss you
all whenever you're not on my TV oh
you're awesome yes so don't get it well
yeah get it and I'm gonna so what
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
tell the real answer that is a better
one which is don't do that
why wouldn't you
oh that's see that's actually a good
point yeah it's not like the first
tattoo no you already got it here right
so that means something to her it it
could get lost in a good way it could
get the emphasis of that would get lost
in the sea of tat of the added upness if
you will yeah yeah that's cool though
I'm saying I get it that's why I get it
you know uh so I I still stick with
don't yeah but if you do I do get it I
say do it but just know people will
blame me for uh for that but yeah but do
it yeah it's cool I think it's cool
we'll even make it about you when it's
like that yeah when it's like what not
bad you know yeah
all right
yeah I think it's cool I I think more
tattoos the better I think so sexy than
that cool yeah wow we caught a glimpse
of the next guy he was so sexy on his
bed just like
very cool I got my [__] sleeve got
going on see this is why I didn't want
to talk about it this is why I didn't
want to talk about tattoos for sure well
because now I gotta take a tour in the
museum
come this way ladies and gentlemen come
this way we've got the Log Cabin here
that's a blueprint right and I added
clouds to it ah get here let me see
there we go no you're good now
Whoopsie Daisy I got the clouds up there
it was a nice day
like the tattoo artist slipped
whoa whoops
[Music]
so but I got the clutch it was a bright
sunny day and I added some clouds to it
so it became a little bit overcast Bob
Ross dude
but then I got the flower and then it
was nice it wasn't connected and then
oopsie Daisy we connected it like that
dude shut right but we did though didn't
we oh we did Imagine giving a [__]
[__] about what you're saying right now
that would be [__] incredible if
someone gave a [__] rat [__] about
that story I'm [__] incredible with
my tats and also I gotta get a [__]
you know what that solidified it oh I'm
getting an eagle like that and I'm in a
[__] an eagle like that okay dead
serious and the [__] wings are gonna
go crazy like crazy out too so it's
gonna look [__] sick dude good luck
to always be alone and naked because
that is a terrible [__] dude no way
when I take my shirt off and by the way
when I get my Eagle take my shirt when I
get the eagle when I the way I take my
shirt off I'm not taking it off like
that anymore I'm straight up going like
this with one hand you're gonna get so
caught I'm gonna
hold on
[Laughter]
oh [__] ah [__] my ankle
um yeah dude that's how I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna only take it off like that
that's cool and it is cool and you're
gonna see the wings first right because
it's gonna come down off the center and
the wing is gonna be peeking out they're
gonna be what's on the show oh sh oh
[__] bro bro
the amount of fantasies
of you
into a microphone
out into the world is out of control
dude
you need help dude
I mean
you do that once every three episodes
you know
stop illustrating fantasies of you oh
[__] thank you ah [__] that's so hot in
here you know I mean it is so hot Nelly
philosophical Nelly
all right all right all right
anytime when you're any guy or a girl if
your hand is near your mouth you up the
level of [__] sex for real yeah
that's why that sexy yearbook photo is
always like this yeah yeah yeah
the guys in Montclair New Jersey when we
were in New Jersey yeah the [__] the
black dudes that would do like this bro
they all looked 35 in high school and
they had the like the game remember
gamerville that guy remember that one is
that in New Jersey oh that was your was
that you were that was mine yeah yeah
and it is because we each got to have
like a caption in the yearbook you know
oh yeah and he was doing this and
underneath was just in all caps
gamerville
which is so sick if you think about it
it's so sick dude and also
um if you look back at those yearbooks
now those black dudes still look 35 go
ahead yeah they all yeah because you
thought they were older than you and now
even though they're not older than you
are now they still look older than you
I'm 43 so you know I'm not sure I
understand what I'm saying is if you do
this so back then you'd look in the
yearbook and you'd be like a sophomore
and you'd look at a senior black dude
that guy looks 35 yeah right right now
when you're older they still look 35.
you're right it's not that you were
younger looking up
yeah what the [__] I kind of picked up
the black don't crack thing yeah I know
well no it's like they don't crack but
still they look older because they look
more mature okay but when you ask me to
paint a picture I really can so when you
said I don't really understand I go like
this I breathe I say it you fully
understand and then we move on
interesting no but interesting okay so
next one sex together see what's up with
the hot sexy dude
I'll see okay oh okay
what's up man what's up Chris wow I'll
just get right to it I live in a condo
and I use the gym there okay you're
[__] his mouth a couple weeks ago I
went in to do a workout I mean and
somebody else walks in this dude just
blaring his own music no good yeah on a
Bluetooth speaker and I got my earpods
in I'm trying to listen to a podcast and
it's turned all the way up I still can't
hear it so then I'm blood red mad yeah
brm and I say okay I'm just gonna pause
my [__] and just ignore it but then he
kept on doing it and other people walked
into the gym and we're all kind of
looking at each other collectively like
what is this guy doing yeah so I said no
screw that I'm gonna say something nice
so I went up and I said that's sexy too
you know that's a loud speaker you got
there and he's like oh yeah it's like
this uh you know Bose version I'm like
just looking at him and then he kind of
sees it in my face and he goes oh you
want me to turn it down I'm like yeah
dude it's kind of loud I can't even hear
my my podcast
but I was done my workout anyway so I
kind of just left I'm not asking you
guys if you think it's wrong I know that
it's wrong but what else would you guys
have said like I want to hear some other
spin moves here thanks guys I actually
was at a you know crave that place
whenever it's a restaurant uh it's one
of those ones my favorite you order at
the counter and then you go to take your
seat and you got the number 65 Nick
because here you go 65 drop it down
right that's my [__] dude I don't like
when the waiters come over and you got
to make it a whole [__] big deal
anyway I digress stop yeah but so that's
a whole nother episode but I was born
most boring episode ever I mean so
here's why I like these guys
congratulations is it's not boy it's not
boring it's good but but
um and yes I will be in Nashville coming
up so go get tickets but the uh
the this I'm sitting waiting for my
coffee I get my coffee start drinking it
all of a sudden this dude walks in in
the in the cafe
with not only a it's like this big a
Bose thing it's across he's got a strap
and it's behind him walking in it's like
oh yeah
cook
that song sounds [__] free me baby oh
yeah let me lick you up and down was it
really that's how you say stop yeah
dude one time when I was in
uh College I was in a
what do you call it room I was roomed
wow forgot the word room roommate my
roommate was anshul Bim Johnny he was
Indian oh no he was something whatever
he was he supported
Osama Bin Laden and that was before I
even the Twin Towers hit so I didn't
know who he was so he was on The Cutting
Edge what do you mean yeah he was like
he would talk about Osama Bin Laden and
he'd be like this guy is actually the
real guy what yeah I don't know what he
was not Indian that was really really
racist that I said that but anyway that
was pretty [__] up uh he uh
I wouldn't know the [__] out of him
because he was annoying and uh and I was
I was singing that once as I was going
to bed and I said uh let me like you up
and uh until you say stop and he says
stop
dude and I will never forget that it was
so funny what's the guy's name again
Johnny well I'm sure that's a [__]
you're a ball or a thing I never met him
but you know the name right yeah that's
yeah
so anyway
um
well the worst anyway all right uh over
the proper punishment oh yeah he had the
[__] Boombox and I didn't say
anything because I was like I want to
ride this out and see how long he's
going to do it he eventually turned it
down so my thing is I'd let the guy have
a few minutes I'd give him a grace
period yeah I think he did but yeah keep
going okay
um that's him yep
wow what a surprise I've looked I've
tried to look him up before what a
surprise turn of events you obviously
didn't try that hard it took Chris 30
seconds
I don't have LinkedIn is that LinkedIn
yep
whoa
whoa does he look so different now look
he went to NYU no it looks exactly the
same trying to find out if Chris is a
liar or not oh lucky lucky he's a good
NYU yeah ask him about his freshman year
roommate
ask him about Osama Bin Laden it could
have been someone else I don't know but
I think it was Osama bin Laden well I
mean all right that was so fun that was
four years before 9 11 though well he
was still he was just a big fan of I
mean he was the biggest figure I know
but it was a big figure wow interesting
yeah okay that was like around when uh
Bill Clinton tried to kill him probably
yeah maybe I don't know really history
that much well I do so I know a lot Bill
Clinton did it
but
Bill Clinton did it different kind of
different different kind of inside job
do you think so no I don't think that
you know what I'm saying an inside job
no you don't think what I don't think
any of the things I said because it was
obviously a joke oh but did someone try
to kill him back then who Osama Bin
Laden yes
oh Osama Bin Laden was
on he was they tried Bill Clinton tried
to assassinate him that's that's not so
you're not [__] no not that part is
not that part is not [__] okay so uh
so British that part is not [__] so
then so then what is [__] that
you're saying that it was an inside job
that it was an inside job by Bill
Clinton but if it was by Bill Clinton
then it wasn't and then it wasn't 911 an
inside job oh dude nobody said 9 11.
yeah I did dude
nobody said we were obviously on tape so
whoever wants to can rewind go back see
what's what's up well I mean all right
that was so [__] that was four years
before 9 11 though well let's definitely
not go back all right let's let's go
back at your leisure but the point is
don't wear a [__] boom box in a cafe
and definitely don't bring it at the gym
because the gym has its own music by the
way sort of the cafe so now this is two
things where it's like a DJ in the
middle of songs mixing it's so annoying
dude the the the ego the you know what
you are you're worse than the guy
playing the guitar at the party you know
what I'm thinking about it I kind of
went off into days there it's because
I'm thinking about this and I'm like
I'm trying to imagine a version of
myself that would do anything like that
that is like so far away from my
character my like down to my fiber like
that is so I would be so keenly aware of
how much I might be bothering other
people yeah you'd feel so bad I would
just like too that would be like you
couldn't pay me enough to do that to
people it's like so [__] crazy for
two grand but okay well
cash okay cool uh but yeah dude that's
just I mean that's Bonkers and so again
I think the response or the thing that
you do when you approach should be
commeasure it too that
complete absurdity to measure it yeah
like make it as absurdive as that if you
want you have a Long Leash because that
is ridiculous Behavior
it's ridiculous dude making other people
listen to your dumb [__] it was [__]
puddle of Mud for sure too what
while puddle of Mud I'm always like
afraid to uh confront people well I'm
afraid to confront people like that
because you think if they're insane
enough to do this then they're probably
insane enough to [__] be true
carrying a gun and would just be like oh
yeah is that what you think that's a bit
overboard but yeah right that does mean
there are a certain level of something
yes they're a wild card for a while
because their brains are obviously
completely [__] [__] up because
they go into a public place blasting
their own [__] stupid [__] up music
yeah so you're not starting out in the
same place already right exactly and I'm
just yeah my risk reward uh but you
gotta just the thing you gotta do is you
gotta act like you are just as crazy if
not more I would go like this what the
[__] right yeah right that's what I
would do but you got to do that early
dude so you got to be ready for [__]
in this world because you got to be
ready to go what the [__] because if you
wait too long then it becomes what this
guy's wondering what do I say what do I
do what do I do but a natural reaction
of that is great so you got to be ready
yeah to give the world that reaction
very good point or you can get an oops
button at chrisley.com and just go hit
him with it stop talking with your own
[__] but yeah right do that yeah I mean
more what I said but yeah yeah but I'm
saying if you have those button you can
work out with it you could do that it's
possible yeah who oh you know what you
do for real right when that guy's doing
good who wants him to turn his music off
raise their hand and then everyone would
raise their hand it's true [__]
hilarious that would be good too that'd
be good dude that requires a lot of
different things though just a reaction
yeah very simple and easy and anyone can
do it okay yeah so one size fits all
reaction to an [__] um
okay all right wanna do another one
um love both of you guys so
um my sister and I are super close I
would assume like you guys and we really
want to start a podcast and so not just
that I want advice on how to start a
podcast like on technical levels on like
merchandise like standards stuff like
that but my main question is we are not
famous like you guys are um you guys
have a lot of Fame and so there was
already clout there put in place to kind
of promote your podcast
what advice do you have for my sister
and I who want to kind of create a
similar vibe in terms of having a
sibling podcast if we have pretty much
no Fame thanks guys love you guys
thank you first of all I would say don't
but if you're going to well I don't
we'll start explaining too many podcasts
I don't agree but but if you're going to
make it about a specific thing find a
lane yeah people will find you yeah you
can blow up that way if it's just hey
we're sisters I don't think it's going
to work I I think you're right yeah I
think you're right but because then you
got you got some
but I uh just to address the first part
of completely dashing her dreams I'm
obviously I'm I'm joking but there are a
lot of podcasts out there and it's a
very hard landscape too right but but
this you got to think of it like there's
somebody out there or some group of
people out there that you've said this
before okay again I'm just saying this
is very truly you and that's good you're
consistent
well there's somebody out there or some
group of people out there that the
podcast that they want to be listening
to is the one you're thinking of
starting yeah so give that to them
that's the way to think of it you're
welcome hold it you're welcome yeah yeah
yeah uh but provide something I think
you find something specific because then
I don't not only are they subscribing to
you they might be like oh this is about
a bad example but this is about you know
Home Furniture I love Home Furniture you
guys talk about home furniture I'm gonna
listen to that right whatever it is
obviously enough Home Furniture but Home
Furniture could be good though yeah the
Home Furniture podcast so boring the
Home Furniture couches it's called
um hi welcome to couches with Amanda and
my sis um yeah so that's uh touches
would actually be a thing I would watch
without question oh yeah 100 just based
off title alone yes couches yes
um yeah so I think that that's my advice
uh other than that
other than that just do it you know stop
waiting just be a pimp and start okay
I'm not sure that just be about about it
Pimp Like get a bunch of women that work
for you that will have sex with men and
you take a cut just be about It Bout It
pimp and Pimpin Booyah Booyah and booyah
yeah it's the same thing three times
okay well all right we want to drive it
home all right so that's it yeah and I
appreciate you guys listening uh
chrisley.com for tour tickets uh I will
be in your area if not yet I'm adding
dates next week I believe next week
um but yeah go to watch lifeline.com if
you have a question or leave us a
message on the hotline 213-973-8095
um one-on-one advice sessions with Matt
at matalia.com and the new Lifeline
merch very cool them purple hoodies are
almost out
lifelimerch.com uh and like And
subscribe please that really helps us
and leave a comment for that algorithm
we'll see you next week guys thank you
very much
hello
[Music]